(brouhaha)
- Depuis une semaine,
le chaos a de nouveau envahi
les rues de Port-au-Prince.
Les Haïtiens n'en peuvent plus
d'avoir peur, d'avoir faim
et de manquer de tout,
y compris d'eatatatable.
"L'eau potable est un problème,
dit cet homme. On en cherche
partout et on ne trouve rien."
Les gangs qui bloquent
des routes, empêchant
la livraison de marchandises,
et l'inflation galopante
ont provoqué des pénuries
de presque toutes les denrées.
Et les stations sont feseses
depuis des semaines.
C'est encore le coût
de l'essence qui a mis
le feu aux poudres.
ARIEL HENRY,
premier ministre d'Haïti
- La misère abjecte
dans laquelle végète un trop
grand nombrenononos concitoyens.
- Dans un rare discours
à la nation, le premier ministre
a annoncé, le 11 septembre,lalas
sur le carburant. Résultat :
le prix de l'essence à la pompe
a plus que doublé, d'un coup.
JEAN DANIEL SÉNAT,
journaliste, "Le Nouvelliste"
- C'est pourquoi les gens sont
en colère : une augmentation des
prix équivaut à une augmentation
des produits de première
nécessité.
(brouhaha)
- La colère populaire a explosé
dans les jours sui
l'annonce du premier ministre.
Des affrontements aux barricades
ont fait au moins un mort
et de nombreux blessés,
et provoqué l'arrêt complet
de l'activité économique.
- Tout est à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui. La semaine
dernière, déjà, il y avait
aucune activité formelle
et informelle, le transport
en commun était à l'arrêt,
les banques, les supermarchés...
Aujourd'hui, il y a
des barricades qui sont levées,
mais cela n'implique pas
une reprise des activités.
- Les subventions sur
le carburant représentaient
le quart de tout le budget
de l'État haitien. Le Fonds
monétaire international a exigé
qu'elles soient supprimées,
en échange de son appui
financier. Mais le faire
d'un seul coup était risqué.
- Cela vient avec
les conséquences que
l'on connaît, avetatatamment
des scènes de pillage dans
les entreprises. Il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui vont
enregistrer d'énormes pertes
après ce mouvement
de protestations.
SÉBASTIEN CARRIÈRE,
ambassadeur du Canada en Haïti
- Quililil y a une période
de manifestations intenses,
il est plus sage pour
la sécurité du public et
des employés canadiens et locaux
de l'ambassade de fermer et
de fonctionner en télétravail.
- L'ambassadeur estime
que la colère des Haitiens
est légitime. Il croit
qu'il faut continuer d'aider
le pays à combattre l'insécurité
chronique, la source de tant
de souffrance. C'est pouiii
le premier ministre Trudeau
présidera demain à New York une
réunion sur la crise haitienne.
- Le premier ministre a décidé
de convoquer cette réunion pour
convaincre d'autres partenaires
à venir avec nous pour renforcer
la police nationale d'Haïti, qui
est, selon nous, la solution aux
problèmes sécuritaires d'Haïti.
- Si la situation sécuritaire
s'améliore, cela permettrait
aux Haïtiens de retourner
travailler et d'organiser
des élections. Car depuis
plus d'un an, les institutions
publiques, comme le parlement et
les tribunaux, sont complètement
dysfonctionnelles.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréa